I honestly think this was the biggest
mistake in any of the Stargate episodes
it just didn't make sense it was not
logical to me and it did take another
episode to fix welcome to Sid Trek your
Sci-Fi TV and moveie channel Stargate is
not like Star Trek or at very least it's
not like new Star Trek Stargate sg1 SG
Atlantis and SGU was always pretty good
at keeping the cannon straight they
didn't really make many mistakes I was
talking to somebody about this and
they're sort of thing the only thing I
can think of was that once they fired a
z without the thing popping up and I'm
like if that's really the biggest
production era they ever made they're
doing pretty good but you could argue
that there's a few storyline errors one
of mine for me is actually that the
replicators reappeared in Stargate
Atlantis that never really made much
sense I don't really know why they did
it that way other than they needed a
reason to bring the replicators into
that series because they wanted a cool
villain but the way they did it that it
was created by the atlantans but in our
galaxy was just created as a
toy I didn't really like that but it
wasn't really an error it was just how
they did it but what is the mistake I'm
talking about well to be honest it's to
do with te and his family in the episode
Bloodlines tiok realizes that his son
ryak is about to have the implantation
he's going to get the gold lava stuck in
his gut and he wants to prevent it he
goes rushing back to chac he finds their
home burned out and he starts to panic
that perhaps his family have been
murdered well after all he is the shova
he did turn on his God of course the God
would be vengeful against his family
that's obvious this is really the
biggest problem I have with the early
episodes of Stargate that in this
episode T hasn't mentioned his family
and then all of a sudden decides he has
to risk his life to go and prevent the
Gold World being implanted into his
belly as he goes through that right of
becoming a Jaffer at no point does he go
you know what aice might murder them he
really might because he's a vengeful God
he's not a very loving God and of course
he would now braac appears and this is
the first time we get to see him Hammond
of Texas I just love that uh as a joke
They carried on throughout the series
but it started in this episode so braek
tells him no he's not dead don't worry
they're over there hiding in a quarry
and tiok arrives just in time to prevent
the implantation now the sg1 team has
gone with them because they want to get
a gold lvy to experiment on now that's
going to be interesting later but if
you've watched the episode you know what
I mean anyway let's get back to the
mistake telk arrives sg1 blows up a
bunch of stuff which would have 100%
been seen by all the guards and things
braac then beats up a couple of guards
at the end of the episode which
again obviously we go straight back to
Aus EX exactly what's happened braak
says I'll cross that bridge when I come
to it and he ends up legging it
basically but rayak and tulk's wife I'm
gonna say this wrong but it's it looks
like dreak to me dreak I only watch the
episode like a week ago I really should
have paid attention to her name
pronunciation but I didn't so he leaves
them on
shac he left them now if aice didn't
kill them the first time round and his
wife does talk about about how she's had
to work really hard to sort of get back
into within the Jaffer people and maybe
try and get a little bit of a place
again so that I mean so that Drea could
even have the implantation but aice
would know that te could been back on
tulac he'd know it loads of people saw
sg1 he'd know that too there is
absolutely no way a propice would leave
these two alive now I know what you're
going to say instead of killing them
apus had a plan he brainwashed ryak and
tried to turn him against te in the
episode family tiok has to go back to
tulac and basically get his wife and son
and he takes them um to another planet
where they can live safely from the go
world I don't know why he didn't do that
the first time I don't know why in the
very first episode children of gods he
didn't go you know what give me two
minutes I need to go and grab my wife
and kid because when I do this O'Neal
and I go with you apus is definitely
going to kill them but he didn't do that
I don't know why then in the episode in
series one Bloodlines he didn't take
them back to the SGC where they would be
safe so I asked Brad Wright what he
thought of this little problem and I'm
going to tell you what he
said I hear you but where would they
stay at
SGC yeah underground and in
secret maybe each carrying a ly gold now
at the point of um the first episode
ryak didn't have a gold lvi so he could
in theory have been brought up like a
human being I think uh maybe um they
could never live in a community what
kind of life would that be now I
actually think Brad's got a point there
could they have gone back to the SGC and
lived something like a normal life well
eventually telk was allowed to live off
base so he could have lived off base
with his family but even when Teel did
start to live off base I know they
didn't last very long but even when he
did at no point did he mention can I get
my wife and kid never mentioned now we
don't know how often he visited his wife
and kid on the planet he sent them to
but as far as We Know didn't stay very
long when he did I'm not sure te liked
his wife very much it's just a suspicion
but ryak if they'd have taken him in the
episode of
Bloodlines didn't have the ly like I
said so he could have been brought up
normally on Earth where he'd been safe
but I would argue there was no way Aus
was not going to get some Revenge at
least on his wife and child or at very
least use them against te
to be honest it makes no sense that he
didn't capture them immediately and get
message to the SGC that TK you return
now or I'm going to murder them I will
murder your wife in front of your son
and then I will murder your son and I
will make sure everybody on Tac sees it
that is what he would have done the only
option for T was to get his wife and son
and take them to the SG DC and then
maybe find them somewhere else that they
could live eventually initially though
take them to the SGC now you could argue
that TK didn't know what he was walking
into so he could have got to the SGC and
he's basically could have been handing
himself over for experimentation which
actually was talked about in the couple
of episodes after T arrived at the um
Stargate command so maybe he didn't
because he was worried about their
safety so in that case why didn't he get
a message to braac immediately and say
please get my wife and kid and get them
the hell out of chewack as quickly as
possible I'm trying to figure out the
situation of where I am now with the T
and as soon as I can I'm going to get
word to you but for the love of God well
not for the love of God because that
would be aice for the love of the non-
goods get my wife and son out of there
that is the only thing that makes sense
as I said they fixed this mistake in the
later episode in season two and he did
get his wife and child out of there over
a year after he first became the shova
but they did fix the problem it just to
me makes no sense that they ever made
the mistake in the first place I don't
really know why they ever gave tiul a
family if they weren't going to follow
through with it because we never really
see them we see ryak a couple of times
but we don't really see the wife in
those two episodes and we never really
hear from her again I think it painted
themselves into a lot of sort of logical
storyline corners and to be honest it
caused a load of problems for T that
they didn't need you could argue that
him turning on aice and joining up with
O'Neal was already a little bit of a
stretch and I can't help with think it's
not just a big error it's really the
biggest error in sg1 but guys I'd love
to know what you think to get across
into the comments are there other
mistakes in SG one that you can think of
other than you know the Zach gun not
popping up once or twice I shouldn't
really do that with a Zach gun because
you know it already looks a little bit
like a sex toy I shouldn't really keep
popping it up but anyway are there any
other plot holes or logical leaps in
Stargate that you can think of please
get into the comments and tell me also
if if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification also you can check the
videos have been ticking along as we've
been chatting they're all Linked In the
description for our Facebook page our
Twitter page or X page what the hell
it's called nowadays and our patreon
page which actually most of our videos
do Premiere first so if you want to see
the videos before everybody else
including those Stargate rumors go and
check it out also there's the citrek web
page
c.co where we do articles based on a lot
of our videos and we try to add a little
bit more information for you to digest
go check that out too as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next
[Music]
time